I didn't mean to hurt anybody's feelings
Wendy Williams in tears apologizing for
comments she made about gay men on
Thursday's episode of her talk show I'm
55 years old and maybe I sounded like
your auntie your mother your big sister
or somebody out of touch I'm not out of
touch except for perhaps yesterday by
saying what I said
so I deeply apologize
let's get you up to speed we've got a
lot to talk about the TV personality
found herself in the hot seat after
Thursday's edition of hot topics because
of these comments look here now
gay men you'll never be the woman that
we are no matter how gay yes during her
show Wendy pulled the audience asking
who plans to celebrate Valentine's Day
here's what she said when men started
clapping well first of all if you're a
man and you're clapping you're not even
a part of this okay I don't care if
you're gay you don't get immensely every
28 days you can do a lot that we do but
I get offended by the idea that we go
through something you will never go
through and stop wearing our skirts and
our heels
just saying girls what do we have for
ourselves major backlash sparked online
and on Friday
Wendy issued her tearful apology video
on YouTube I'll start by saying I
apologize I did not mean to offend my
lgbtq+ community on yesterday's show I
never do the show in a place of malice I
understand my platform with the
community from first grade to
intermediate school to high school to
college to radio and now to TV I will do
better for better or worse wendy has
built an entire career off of keeping it
super real which et saw firsthand in
2014 where she opened up about being
herself and owning it I've always only
wanted to be me because it's too hard to
fake being somebody else like and if
there's one thing that I get delight in
is when people say oh so this on TV girl
is the same off TV girl I am and you
might not get me on my how you doin vest
at the grocery store but you know what I
give you that on the show too if I'm not
feeling something so if I you know I
I'm my own inspiration
[Music]